let's continue taking call 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 is the number we will go now to
the 9 1 0 area code caller and 9 1 0
what's your name where are you calling
from and what's your question today
hello hello my name is Darren and I'm
calling from Fayetteville North Carolina
great and I have more of a point to make
than a question sorry I'm really upset
that Donald Trump getting a peach still
gives us the Republican Party because
that's really the ultimate outcome
consequence of the temp that we ended up
with the Republicans of power when it
shouldn't have been so how come nobody's
talking about how to address that well
listen I'm talking about it I've been
very clear where I've said the Russia
investigations should happen whatever it
is that is the appropriate resolution to
whatever took place is what's going to
have to happen but from a strategic
point of view Democrats should be aware
of the fact that Trump a scandal-ridden
Trump for the next three and a half
three years would however long it is at
this point unable to get anything John
right I mean the wall is not happening
tax reform is dead Obamacare repeal
didn't happen infrastructure spending I
don't know what's going on with that
right things happening day run that
might almost be better than a quick
Trump impeachment which puts pence and
Paul Ryan at the head of the Republican
Party both of whom are absolutely
they're people I'm ideologically opposed
to but are much more efficient
legislators than our Donald Trump so I
think you're absolutely right about this
and I've been talking about it every
opportunity I can get and my point is
why are we doing something about the
electoral college and and why are we
passing some type of legislation that if
you're a piece for tempering with the
election that you're whole we have a new
election for example I'm yeah right
right right that seems reasonable to me
that seems reasonable to me it's not
gonna why don't we why are we moving in
that way well we
the Republican House Senate White House
and moderately conservative Supreme
Court how do you even do it and I get
what you're saying de Iran I get the
anger and the frustration because the
system we have even if we see Trump
removed it's still going to give us an
absolute and total disaster but aren't a
lot of these ideas Pat right now you're
such right and also we got Gorsuch your
said yes it would require a
constitutional amendment which happens
so few and far between the last time it
happened was a generation ago in the
1970s so I think you know abolishing the
electoral college would be a good one to
wrap everyone around and could may
actually have a successful a chance at
happening but it still is a tall task
and there are actually people day Ron I
don't know if you've heard about this
there are people who now say they don't
believe there should be any more
constitutional amendments in other words
they there are people who have emailed
me who say we started with the
Constitution it wasn't perfect so we did
the Bill of Rights but that's it no more
amendments period and some of the things
you're talking about require a
constitutional amendment and I worry I'm
being the messenger of bad news here but
some of these things are not going to
happen okay but we're in the
Constitution says that we're supposed to
have a two-party system where if the
presidents and teachers vice president
is because the president yeah well
that's the way it works
that's just the way it works if the
president is impeached the Vice
President becomes the president but yeah
listen I understand the frustration the
bill over it's in the amendment to the
Constitution yes yeah all right they Ron
thanks very much appreciate the call
bringing up I sense the frustration in
Darrin's voice and I I appreciate that
and I understand it let's take a break
we will take some more phone calls
coming up 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 you can also
chat with us on our reddit discussion
forum at david pakman.com slash read it